My guest this week is the former U.S.
military intelligence analyst Chelsea
Manning.
When she was 22, she made a decision
that would change the rest of her life.
She chose to leak hundreds of thousands
of military reports to WikiLeaks about
the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan.
In a bet, she would say, to educate the
public about what was really going on.
She was then arrested, held in a metal
cage and found guilty of theft and
espionage sentence for 35 years in
prison.
President Barack Obama later commuted
that senses after seven years served.
Now she's put her account in a new book.
And I want to ask her why she did what
she did.
Chelsea Manning, welcome to the program.
Thank you so much for joining me.
Thank you.
You were just 22 in 2010 working for the
U.S.
military as an intelligence analyst.
When you made a decision that would
change the rest of your life, actually
sitting in a bookshop back in America,
you decided to leak hundreds of
thousands of U.S.
military reports about the wars in both
Iraq and Afghanistan to WikiLeaks.
Why?
Well, I mean, you know, there were so
sick, a whole series of events that
occurred before this.
And as I write in the book,
I know there there's a whole sequence of
events that led up to this.
I had spent several months in Iraq.
I had
been an intelligence analyst for quite,
quite some time.
At this point, and it came to I came to
the realization that in my role and
gradually as I was doing in this
position, that there was a vast
discrepancy, a huge chasm and a distance
of this sort of understanding between
what I what gradually came to be on the
ground, reality of what I was seeing on
the ground in Iraq and in Iraq into a
slightly lesser extent now in
Afghanistan versus what the public was
aware of.
And yet, I wonder if you asked an
average American on the street, could
they name something that you revealed in
that file?
Could they could they think of something
that they had learned before you leaked
it?
Do you think that they could or what
should come to mind that you revealed to
the world that they didn't know before?
No, I unfortunately.
And, you know, part portions of the
document, portions of the Booker
redacted because the U.S.
government won't allow me to disclose
that information.
But but the nature of what your source
of talking about, you know, it's been
reported, it included footage which
showed U.S.
soldiers allegedly targeting civilians.
And then what turned out, as it's been
reported, to be a Reuters photographer,
for instance.
So so that's what I.
Well, allegedly, I mean, it has that
that that was that was found, I think.
Yes.
Sorry.
But my point is you're talking about
reduction and what we're able to say and
how things were reported as well at the
time.
But but
it's got sources saying that your you
were trying to share with people that
essentially the military wasn't acting.
How people perhaps thought.
Well, I think it's actually more
complicated.
Not even using that video as an example.
You know, it's less of a black and white
and it's more of a gray.
It's a gray scale video in that it shows
the sort of complexities that are
involved.
It shows, you know, not just an attack
on a Reuters journalist, which is what
journalists seem to care about, but also
on, you know, a vehicle with, you know,
of unarmed civilians and then the people
on the ground, the soldiers on the
ground who when they uncover and reveal
and it's revealed to them like, oh,
there are no injured children involved
in this, you know, then you know that
you sort of see the best of young U.S.
soldiers on the ground to try to, you
know, seek medical attention for four
kids.
So I think that it's a much more
complicated affair in depth.
That's the that's a whole reality of
21st century asymmetric warfare.
You know, in this timeframe is it is
messy, but essentially we're just trying
to show
the good.
You were trying to show the bad.
You were trying to show what wasn't
being reported in your view.
Do you feel that that's a grasp on the
truth was held by the American public
through your leaking?
I don't know.
You have to ask them.
I feel like that was the goal and the
intention.
But sure, the American public, you know,
has this information available to them
now.
But, you know, also served as history.
So to other points of time ahead of us.
So I you know, it's said it wasn't yours
to give.
You were convicted of espionage.
You were convicted of theft.
And I was not.
Look, I had a court martial and there
were charges of unauthorized disclosure.
But, you know, like the
like, it doesn't belong.
And, you know, this kind of it for me,
if you can't hold on to this
information, you're not going to be able
to in the 21st century.
That's that's the point I'm making.
As you say, you can you can ask the
American public how they feel about
that.
And for some, they did.
You will be aware of this.
He was a traitor.
I mean, they hide.
I don't I don't encounter that on a
daily basis.
I don't know.
But you will be a what?
You will be aware that there is that
view because of I mean, there's a view.
There is a view.
But it's usually among like people who
are, you know, hardly relevant to the
21st century society that mobilized the
people that that see these kinds of
things are, you know, your are are
usually people in powerful positions or
are in, you know, you know, who are
older.
So I generational I think there's a sort
of generational difference between sort
of people who are aware of the of how
widespread, you know, having access to
information is in this era of, you know,
we live in the era of radical
transparency.
Now, that's the sense that I get.
Let's say that there are those who who
agree with what you're sort of what
you're talking about, the themes and the
principles.
But they still feel uncomfortable about
the way you released the information to
WikiLeaks.
What would you say to them that, you
know, did you do everything you could do
to try and work within the systems that
existed that were available to you,
within the army, within the military?
There are there?
Yeah.
Those systems don't exist.
And, you know, it's look, we can we can
rehash this kind of history.
And obviously, I took responsibility for
what happened.
I made this decision.
I know I did these things, you know, and
I went through a court martial and I
went through this process.
So, you know, like we've we've gone
through this.
This is just you've written a book about
it.
So I think it raises the questions
again.
You say rehashing, I'm just trying to
hear from you
what you think has changed as a result
of it and how you engage with those who
didn't feel comfortable.
I think I think that I think I think
that now we live in a very different
era.
So I think in the 20, 22, for instance,
you know, as a
as a civilian, you know, I got my laptop
computer in 2022.
I look at
I can look at the Russian invasion of
Ukraine, for instance.
And I see that, you know, now we're so
watching information, I feel like I have
more access to information about an
ongoing conflict and say, you know,
March or April 20, 22 than I did as an
intelligence analyst in a classified
environment in 2010.
Do you feel that about the U.S.
military?
Do you feel it's more open now that you
have more access to that source?
I do.
I do think so.
I think that there's been I mean, you
know, the 2010s or a turbulent sort of
era for large institutions.
We're encountering wides, the widespread
access of information for the first time
we saw this obviously in 2010, we saw
this in 2013 with with with with the
others, a set of leaks that happened in
2013.
We see this with cell phone cameras
where, you know, and broadband Internet
access being more widespread and
available with, you know, cell phone
camera footage of, you know, police
brutality, you know, causing
controversies now.
So I think I think that we do live in an
era in which, you know, now there's
because of the amount of that.
I mean, in fact, there's too much
information.
We're not now in year out where it's
very hard to discern in, you know,
valuable information.
Information is validated from
disinformation and misinformation.
Yeah, of course, the verification of
information is is a major battle.
You talk about what happens to you.
And I want to go into that, which you
talk about in the book as well.
But just on that point of writing this
and putting it in a book.
Who's this book for?
Who are you hoping to tell your story to
or convince perhaps of of why you did
what you did or what you were hoping to
achieve?
So I view this book as a coming of age
story for me, and I've aimed this book
towards a younger version of myself.
Right.
You know, this is essentially a book
that I wrote with myself at the age of
of 15 in mind.
Right.
And I dedicated this book to sort of
young trans people as well who are, you
know, and.
And that that's that's how I view this
is this is you know, I I'm not that much
of a fan of the thriller novel.
So I didn't want to tell that kind of
story.
I wanted to tell as coming of age story
because because I mean, it's not even
really a memoir.
This is about a time period in my life
in which I am, you know, very young and
I'm still kind of young.
Yes, you are.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm in my mid 30s, so I'm just
starting to get my life together.
Well, it's quite a coming of age story
because as of then, as you say, taking
responsibility, what happens to you?
You're transported to Kuwait and the
metal bar cage for 49 days is part of
your experience.
Well, you tell me.
But I did want to ask because you do
then go on to do several spells of
solitary confinement.
But can you describe what that is like
for us?
Sure.
So the, you know, solitary confinement
is
it's hard.
It's kind of hard to describe and was
actually really hard to write about
because.
There's not a lot that's happening right
now, is it?
There's a lot of sensory deprivation.
There is a
sort of focus on food, on sleep, on just
trying to regulate your own body.
And I remember in Kuwait in particular,
it's actually very fuzzy and foggy
because of how hot it was.
It was, you know, like in the high
thirties to tie down Templeton to mid
40s in temperature, know, in Kuwait.
And I was
and was like there were.
It was dark.
And, you know, it's like I just.
It's very hard to write about the time
period.
You know, for for no different reasons,
you know, because there's not a lot
happening.
And also, there's just this hyper
awareness that starts develop on the
sort of conditions around you.
And.
And dislikes this sense of self and the
sense of like aware self awareness about
about yourself.
I mean, it almost feels like a more
animalistic period, you know, for a fort
for me where, you know, it's not like I
I'm not even thinking almost in in
words.
I'm just thinking of just food and and
sleep and and trying to get through the
next period of time and survival.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
I mean,
I read and you tell me again that you
didn't think you were actually going to
go to prison and then for doing what you
did.
So you go from that to this, which is
such an extraordinary contrast, I
imagine, as well.
Yeah, and you know, it was it was very
unexpected.
You know, this is never this has never
happened before.
So what would you have, though?
Would you still leave Chelsea if you
knew you were gonna go to prison?
You know, I.
Know I'm not going to speculate on what
I I'm what what I would have done if if
I'd known something different.
But I look, I can't change what
happened.
I can't do anything about, you know, or
I would have been a different person if
I had made any other decisions.
It would've required me to sort of have
a different background or for a
different set of circumstances.
But I think that I think that even
if you had the potentiality of losing my
career and the potentiality of being
discharged and of losing my security
clearance and essentially being cast
aside and cast out of the military and
essentially barking back at Starbucks
gave me pause.
You know, it was.
That was definitely enough to that.
That was definitely enough to be that
was that I viewed those know in terms of
like having a career at this time.
Is these were these were major
consequences.
And then there were the consequences,
which were much more major, as you as
you say, and you get a sentence of 35
years and going to America then in jail.
And I also understand you.
You were in a position where you tried
to take your own life.
On two occasions, which gives a sense to
anyone who's just perhaps coming to your
story about how difficult this was.
I have had quite a journey.
And obviously, you know, there are time
periods in which you you lose hope and
you give up and you know, but you can
also get past that.
And and I'm thankful that I'm here, that
I have been able to
grow and develop and meet people and
have the friends and support network and
the, you know, the wonderful people that
I have in my life and and that I'm able
to see my family again.
It doesn't end up being for five years
because Barack Obama commuted your
sentence.
President Barack Obama, one of his last
acts as president.
Why do you think he freed you?
What's your take on that?
Well, I mean, he said what the reason
why.
Which is, you know, Chelsea served a
tough sentence and, you know, it was
disproportionate.
Yeah.
He's obviously weighed in.
We didn't hear, you know, Sonia.
It's not it's not that he he views it as
that.
You know, I didn't do anything.
I didn't do anything wrong at all.
Right.
You know, in his mind.
So but, you know, I took responsibility.
I
served a significant period of time in
prison.
So that that was his rationale.
That was someone who stated people may
not realize he did go back to jail in
2019 to 2020.
This is when you refused to testify
before a grand jury investigating Julian
Assange.
Well, I mean, we I want to clarify,
please.
Because the U.S.
got it, because the U.S.
government never acknowledged that.
And they actually denied that it was
targeting a specific individual.
So we don't know.
I do know that I was asked specific
questions regarding the 2010
disclosures.
So I my lawyers obviously speculated
that it might be about a specific
individual.
But but from from out, from our
perspective, it could have been anybody.
It was not limited to a specific
individual.
And on that point, then, for what you do
know, what we know, what we now know,
you don't know as well.
Why didn't you want to do that?
So the grand jury process is is a very
problematic one in the US.
It's used almost exclusively against
people in very high profile political
cases, in various instances throughout
history.
This has been used to sort of go after
people whenever they've like.
Double jeopardy is at play or immunity
has already been conferred or something
like that.
And so I viewed this as sort of the U.S.
government getting back at me for.
For what?
For the commutation of of in 2017.
For what happened.
I see that that's that's your reasoning
because some took that.
I know that you're saying about the
individual, but some people took that.
Well, may have taken us as your support
for Julian Assange.
Is that right?
I look, I don't.
I know that I know that there was an
indictment that was unsealed during the
process, and so the fact that an
indictment was unsealed during that
process and I was still incarcerated,
I fought for something that had already
been indicted, leads me to believe that
it wasn't for that.
So obviously the investigation at that
time was for something bigger, a body
support Julian Assange.
I find it I find it problematic that the
U.S.
government is going after the
individuals involved in the events of
2010.
Yes, OK.
Are you in touch?
Do you have a relationship because it
was WikiLeaks to to which you released
these document?
I I I don't I don't I don't.
I don't know if I've ever had any direct
contact.
OK.
It's just I was speaking and it's a
chance on the record to to say what you
want to say about that.
Well, I find it probably I find a
problem that I like.
I obviously, you know, then going after
the, you know, all of the people
involved in the disclosures, I think in
this manner and in this way, as I think
is, I think very problematic.
And I think that as this unfolds and and
as it grows
and it goes and it gets and, you know, I
don't know how much for I don't know who
else is going to be brought into this.
I don't know how much bigger it's going
to get.
But, you know, I'm alarmed at this at
this case and and how the U.S.
government is is approaching this.
That's all I can say is.
I mean, do you feel it's over as you.
Do you still worry about this?
Is this something that keeps you up at
night?
I think it's over for me.
For me personally, I think that, you
know, this is a chapter that is closed.
You know, I've said what I've said.
I've gone on record.
You know, I you know, I have I've taken
responsibility.
I think that I think that and I'm eager
to get on with my life.
I'm eager to know one of the reasons I
wrote this book was to essentially, you
know, go on record and to build and to
grow and to and to say, look, you know,
like, you know, go to the book, you
know, like here, here's my story for
four for the stuff that happened 12
years ago that almost has no bearing on
my daily life.
Yes.
But going back to jail in 2019 20 says
he must been extremely difficult, to say
the least,
I imagine.
No.
Now, it wasn't it wasn't a dark period
to have to be back without your freedom.
No, I honestly, I'm still I'm so
severely institutionalized that I know
that the idea of going back to jail is
honestly, jail is not a scary place to
me.
It is.
You know, I think that there's there's a
part there's a there's a kernel inside
of me that sort of views,
you know, prison as being beat, being
sort of like just like high school or
just like,
you know.
Yeah, I think so.
I think that it is fascinating.
It's a place where I've spent a
significant period of time.
And I find it difficult.
I honestly find it more difficult out
here because I've spent so much time in
prison that I kind of view the world
through the lens of prison first,
because like I understand sort of how
prison and institutions work.
I mean, obviously, school, military,
prison and, you know, out here is a bit
messier.
And I'm still trying to navigate things.
And it's it's kind of tough.
No, I just I just find that really
fascinating because
you what you seem to be saying, but you
tell me is that being free could be
harder, be more frightening at times,
especially if you've if that's what you
know.
Right.
Because what I know there's a
familiarity with being an imprisoned
environment.
Right.
And in a castle environment, like
there's a familiarity with that.
Like, I know what tomorrow brings and
that kind of environment.
I know how the I know sort of high how
the social dynamics work.
I know, you know, it's a very you know,
it's very structured kind of
environment.
And now here it's messier.
You miss prison in any way.
I think that there I certainly think
that ledge, just like any other
institution that, you know, somebody can
stay out for a significant time.
I think that there is a nostalgic
feeling that comes with with that.
It doesn't necessarily mean that, you
know, that I want that, you know,
obviously, you know, prison is not is
not it's not an ideal place to be in.
But, yeah, I think that there is a that
you know, I certainly have.
Just like just like in combat and being
in a war zone like that and establishing
feelings that come with those kinds of
time and time frames and the sense and
the sense of support that you that that
I had from, you know, from either, you
know,
the other inmates that I had or
different from the friends that I built
or the friend the relationships that I
built.
Well, I was also going to come on to you
know, we talked a bit about how some may
feel not favorably towards what you do,
but it's also been reported that you
received two hundred and seventy
thousand lessons did in prison.
Yes.
I mean, it's extraordinary.
Can you tell us a little bit about that?
Sure.
I received so many letters, I couldn't
read them off.
I do remember that the United States
disciplinary barracks, the prison that
we had.
I think they had to hire additional
staff in order to go through it all
because they obviously couldn't hand
stuff over to me and I didn't get.
And I did keep some of the negative
pieces.
I think I've got 11 pieces of negative
mail the entire time.
Okay.
So, you know, you're someone who likes
your statistics and that's a pretty good
ratio.
Yeah, well, I you know, it's I'm a data
scientist.
It's what I do.
Oh, are you still a data scientist?
Because I was a reader, as someone
described you recently as a socialite.
I see you in vogue, posing and also you
as a deejay.
So you seem to have several several
roles at the moment.
Yeah, I you know, I I'm I'm doing all of
the things that I that that I didn't
that I missed and that I didn't get to
get to do now.
Now that I've written the book, which
took up quite a chunk of time, you know,
I'm able to sort of do these things.
And obviously the pandemic sort of, you
know, is there a messy few years?
So I I do a number of different things.
But but ultimately, I would say that
currently my job is essentially to be a
security consultant.
I work for a man.
I worked for a number of different
clients, one of whom is a privacy
focused company that is working on a
privacy based project that I that
actually, you know, is based on an idea
that I proposed in 2016.
OK.
So that's that's kind of the day job and
by night deejay party attend to whatever
whatever topic.
Yes.
I I have been known to I've been known
to be a party animal throughout my life.
Chelsea Manning, thank you very much for
talking to me.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again.
Take care and goodbye.